Follow up to last week, shoulder issue, rotator cuff, got a MRI and a prediseled wrap last week, Tuesday, 12-day, 40 milligram per day, taper, four days before the scan last Tuesday, sorry, every time that beeps.
I think you guys hear that beat of somebody trying to get in.
They did a cervical and cervical CT scan, I think, in a lot of degeneration, C5, C6.
Results showed more degeneration and nerve issues, really now, rotator cuff.
C6 affects the neck, arm, and thumb.
So, you want to understand the nerve pathways if you make a okay side with your hand, like if you're making an okay side, if you did it with your left hand, it looks like the number six.
So, you've got the other fingers up and you've got the okay side, that's how you remember, that's your C6 nerve, it actually affects half of your longest finger, and then all of your pointer finger, your thumb, and up the lateral side.
You're standing in an anatomical position, it's the lateral side, the radial side of your arm.
The lateral issues came up with vertebral bodies, bone marrow, multilevel scattered vertebral stir, hyper sensitivities, with corresponding T1 hyposensitivity hypotencities, most pronounced at C5, with T2 stir, hyper-intensity and metral epidural space measuring 10 millimeters in the radiocodal dimension.
And more subtle T2 stir, hyper-intensity and the ventral epidural space behind the C6 vertebral body suspicious for epidural spread of tumor, no compression fractions.
So, let's back up here just a little bit.
So, if you do a CT scan or an MRI, you have a lot of degeneration, you could have degeneration.
Just about everybody, as we age, we have degenerative disc disease, that is a degenerative arthritis, or we used to be called wear and tear arthritis.
That's common, it's almost in everybody, that's how we're used to be 6-2 now, I'm 6-1, you lose height of your disc that's caused lock, that's called loss of inhibition of your disc space.
That's normal, so this degeneration is normal, a degenerative disc is not pathological, meaning it's not from pathological disease like cancer.
So, metastasis of cancer would not cause this, now understand, you could have this, plus you could have metastasis of cancer.
So, they're talking about sterile hyperintensities that's talked about possible increase metabolic activity because of possible metastasis.
So, when this is listed, they're thinking about metastasis.
This piece does not have to do with metastasis, this is possible metastasis.
If you have metastasis to the spine, that can cause issues, decrease calcium in the vertebral bodies, and you could get some narrowing of the vertebral body without complete destruction of the vertebral body, destruction of the vertebral body would be pathological.
And that could be enough on top of this to start to cause morbidities of pain, so pain that radiates through pathway, the peripheral nerve pathway.
This person goes on to say there were no compression fractures, so good, that would be more later stage.
Remember, when you have metastasis to the bone, it's elitic, which means it breaks down the bone, it's eroding the bone, eroding erosion, and then you end up with lack of bone density.
And if it's a weight-buried bone, you could end up with a compression fracture, it's called pathological fraction.
Okay, so question is, could trauma, having the trauma and previous predisone, do you think this could be affecting the scan?
You know, I don't think that would affect the scan, so I don't, the hyperintensive is what they're concerned with possible metastasis.
Schedule to do per nouveau in a few weeks, not to sure if that will be any cleaner or not.
Well, there's still debate on that, whether that'll be clear, I think that's a good thing to do, I think just more testing would be good, there's zero invasiveness with the per nouveau scan.
I do have slow differential metastatic disease scattered throughout the vertebra bodies, but no paid anywhere else.
Orthopedic guy said that C5, C6 cause is what's causing the arm and shoulder pain.
I don't agree, doesn't mean that, so don't think that just because CT scan of your shoulder ruled out rotator cuff, all they're looking for is a tear.
So if they don't see any tear in the rotator cuff, you know, they're instantly really dealt the rotator cuff, well, you can still have, you can still have, you know, muscular strain,
that they won't see on MRI, so don't, you know, doctors equally make the mistake to that, oh, you have cancer.
Oh, we don't see any rotator cuff tear, so it's probably because metastatic disease, and that's what it is.
So don't let them jump to that conclusion completely either.
And though you might have some metastasis, some increased intensity in different areas here, it doesn't, you know, it doesn't mean you don't have a core ability of a muscle,
straight, or ligament to straight, flip that around, and that could be the real issue.
So don't give up on treating it from a muscular skeletal point of view.